when you uh read this book and you think
about where you are in your career and
the kinds of movies you have done do you
respond to the tone of this
story or the scope of the story or are
they no it's really so i've done um
you know movies like night at the museum
and and real steel and movies that are
broader and more complex
much bigger budgets i was really hungry
to do a movie where my job was just
basically bringing the writing to life
with the acting and kind of laying back
and giving all my kind of attention and
nurturance to the performances and to
the casting and then to getting the best
out of each actor jane what were you
hungry to do and was john with sean
showing up at the right time with the
right
right
um
you follow the word you follow the good
word the good scripts
my friend who is the producer who bought
the book before it was published paula
weinstein
um had been talking to me about the
project for about six years and uh
didn't know whether
the studio would want a jewish woman to
play the part and then when it turned
out that it wasn't jewish and that this
one was auditioning actors i said i
gotta i want to audition because i i
want that part i identify with her i can
play her i want to do it
i got to stop and rewind you wanted to
audition
yeah well i knew he was auditioning so
you know what am i going to do say i'm
not going to audition but i want the
part well that is what a lot of people
say i mean
they in many ways they are and i know
you know guys there's i mean this room
is filled with people who work in our in
our trade and in our our craft and
you know
kind of is so many people it's so easy
to get complacent but the jane fonda
who you know at
after all she's accomplished with two
oscars in her house said i want to come
in and i want to show what i can do
i want to show it so i give myself a
chance
i yeah i think that that is so inspiring
as you're putting the cast together how
are you trying to figure out how they
look like as a family and as you cast
certain actors are you making
adjustments to what they're going to say
and what they're going to do in the
screenplay yeah um i i met and
auditioned i think more actors on this
movie than any i'd done you know for
instance in the book and in the original
versions of the script uh it was a pure
jewish family so for j when it was jane
for instance we made that dad was jewish
and mom wasn't um when we cast adam
driver who plays philip the youngest
brother he had such a kind of odd and
fantastically unique quality his rhythms
are really kind of off and so jonathan
and i would rework that role so that it
felt more organic to his voice and
similarly bateman who's the master of
dry
arch wit we brought it closer to his
voice and the kind of voices the
characters revealed themselves and then
tailored themselves or rather we
tailored the dialogue around the voice
of the given actor so you're working
with the novelist and the screenwriter
and jonathan had said when he sold the
book that he wanted to be the
screenwriter what were the most intense
conversations you had about the
adaptation
interestingly it's the opposite of what
people assume the general fear is that
if the novelist writes the screenplay
they'll be too faithful to kind of
rigidly adherent to the novel
what jonathan had done is i think
jonathan
assumed that for a movie like this to
get made it needed to be a broader
comedy than the book was and so when i
decided to make the movie the draft at
that point was quite a bit more broad it
had like the siblings sneaking into
dad's sporting goods store and falling
off the roof and it was a broader kind
of thing so our process was i went back
to my copy of the novel where i had
underlined specific lines that i found
just magnificent because i think
jonathan is a
really magnificent writer and our work
together was me saying to jonathan
you need to
you need to be more loyal to your book
you need to not be shy
about honoring
your prose in screenplay form and so we
brought a lot more of the dramatic
content from the novel into the
screenplay and movie what was it like
working with actors who are probably
going to be as inclined to improvise as
they are to to read a script
well i had done a lot of improv in drama
you know coming home was
very much improv but improv comedy is
something totally different
and i learned very fast that i can't do
it
and to be completely in awe of those who
can and here are these people who are
the best and uh
it was just and i just sort of sat there
with my chin on my chest
i'm wondering in your initial
conversations about how you wanted to
play this character and sean what you
wanted out of it what were the kinds of
things you talked about and what were
the commonalities of your conversation i
don't remember
it's what one thing tell me well well
i don't know whether any of this seeped
in um
first you know we just did a little kind
of just to connect more jane and i had
dinner with tina in new york and i
brought my my jewish stepmom down from
montreal just because i felt like there
was a warmth and a kind of i don't know
there's a word like hamisha it's just
like firmpth
yes firm i what is i don't actually know
means firm and warm okay so that yeah um
we talked about it a bit but the truth
is i feel like jane brought
so many of the right instincts because
as you've said to me jane uh the kind of
hillary's sexual candor hillary's kind
of sharing over sharing i'm sure you you
say it's it's often been to the
embarrassment of your own children so
that's something you related to and
totally yeah
my son takes me to lunch i think
probably once every three months he's an
actor troy garrity and he'll take me to
lunch where my daughter-in-law and well
mom
it's come to my attention that last week
you said or did such and such and i
think maybe
you need to cool it
or you're what you're wearing right now
mom
trying too hard
you know and it's cool when that happens
but anyway so i do identify with her and
and so so much i feel like we didn't
really have to build a character from
scratch because the reason jane got the
part is jane so much of what she brought
her warmth her firm her
transparency
her bluntness um that's what hillary
needed to be and also hillary needed to
be a kind of estimable matriarch she
needed to be a major
presence in this family and jane fonda
brings that into the room with her thank
you
i'm curious as you're not only shooting
the film but going through editorial
where did you see the movie going and
the tone of it ended up being one of the
bigger struggles that you had and in
which way were you kind of scaling back
um
the truth is the you know like any time
you direct a movie you follow your
instinct on this stuff and um i'm aware
that the movie is both you know very
profane in points and it has
it's got a fair bit of swearing and it
has some sexual jokes and boob stuff and
all that but and that it also
asks the audience to stick around
and invest in what will be hopefully
poignant moments um and you know if the
movie succeeds hopefully we get those
laughs but we also get those moments
that are moving you know when
when philip and
you know judd touch foreheads when
judd's leaving hopefully we've earned
the right for a moment like that too um
so much of it is intuitive i don't have
a a great answer to that so sean what is
it like when you're working with actors
who have such radically distinct styles
some are going to go off books some are
going to riff jane is probably going to
say her dialogue as it's written what do
you do on on the day well i think this
is true in any movie
i i felt it the most kind of acutely on
this movie because it was
7 to 11 of us in a room in a real house
for 25 days straight so that's a real
house we were in that living room and um
so i i was very conscious of what what
happens on every movie as a director i
don't know how it is for other
filmmakers in in this room but
what i love about the job is you have to
tailor your language
to each actor anyway that's the job you
don't give a note from behind the camera
a i don't ever give a note publicly like
that and then i really try and customize
you know how i speak to my actors so
with jane for instance i'll just i would
go and i'd sit in the shiva chair next
to her and i would make suggestions
about maybe you know how we might take
the scene a certain way whereas with
with someone like um
you know with someone like adam driver i
don't want him in his head
that guy is is great because he's pure
instinct so with adam i said as little
as possible and
i i kind of let him surprise himself
bateman and tina are brilliant
improvisers but thankfully they're both
also producers and filmmakers in their
own right so they know what a scene
needs to accomplish so you know one
example for instance is the scene where
tina's trying to get bateman to tell
everyone about his divorce and she's
pulling his hair that scene is fifty
percent written fifty percent improvised
and yet um you know that was a matter of
i went to ja to tina and i said make him
tell do anything you have to make him
tell and then i went over to bateman and
i said shut her up
shut her up don't reveal your secret and
then we rolled and i said action so it's
always great of course when you have two
actors playing radically opposing
objectives